The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
As you're settling in, why don't
you take 10 more seconds
to answer the clicker
question.
This is the last question we'll
see in class on the
photoelectric effect, so
hopefully we can have a very
high success rate here to show
we are all ready to move on
with our lives here.
OK, good.
So, most of you did get
the answer correct.
For those of you that didn't,
you, of course, can ask your
TA's about this in recitation,
they'll always have a copy of
these slides.
But just to point out the
confusion can be we've
actually switched what
the question is here.
What the information we gave was
the work function, which
is what we've been giving
before, but now we gave you
the kinetic energy of the
ejected electron, so you just
need to rearrange your equation
so now you're solving
for the incoming energy, which
would mean that you need to
add those two energies
together.
So, hopefully everyone that
didn't get this right, can
look at it again and think about
asking it's just asking
the question in a different
kind of a way.
All right.
So, we can switch over
to the class notes.
So today, we're going to
start talking about
the hydrogen atom.
Now that we have our Schrodinger
equation for the
hydrogen atom, we can talk about
it very specifically in
terms of binding energies and
also in terms of orbitals.
And we talked about on Wednesday
the conditions that
allowed us to use quantum
mechanics, which then enable
us to have the Schrodinger
equation, which we can apply,
and part of that is the
wave particle duality
of light and matter.
So there was a good question in
Wednesday's class about the
de Broglie wavelength
and if it can
actually go to infinity.
So I just wanted to address that
quickly before we move
on, and actually address another
thing about dealing
with wavelengths of particles
that sometimes comes up.
So, the question that we had in
last class, was if we have
actually a macroscopic particle,
and the velocity
let's say starts to approach
zero, shouldn't we have the
wavelength go to infinity, even
if we have a magic board,
and even if the mass
is really large.
So, in most cases, you would
think that as the velocity
gets very tiny, the mass is
still going to be large enough
to cancel it out and still
make it such that the
wavelength is going to be
pretty small, right.
Because if we think about the
h, Planck's constant, here
that's measured in 10 to the
negative 34 joules per second.
So, we would actually need a
really, really, really tiny
velocity here to actually
overcome the size of the mass,
if we're talking about
macroscopic particles, to have
a wavelength that's going
to be on the order.
So, let's say we're talking
about the baseball, have a
wavelength of the baseball
that's on the
order of the baseball.
So, if we kind of think about
the numbers we would need, we
would actually need a velocity
that approached something
that's about 10 to the negative
30 meters per second.
So first of all, that's
pretty slow here.
It's going to be hard to measure
anyway, and in fact,
if we're talking about something
going 10 to the
negative 30, and we're going to
observe it using our eyes,
so you using visible light to
observe something going this
slow, we're actually not going
to be able to do it because
we're limited by the wavelength
of light to see how
precise we can measure where
the actual position is.
So let's say we have the
wavelength of light somewhere
on the order of 10 to the
negative 5 meters, being the
wavelength of light, we're
only going to be able to
measure the velocity because of
the uncertainty principle
to a certain degree.
And it turns out it's three
orders of magnitude that --
the uncertainty is three orders
of magnitude bigger
than the velocity that we're
actually trying to observe to
get to a point where we could
see the wavelength, for
example, for even a baseball
that is moving this slow?
So that the more complete answer
to the question is that
no, we're never going to be able
to observe that because
of the uncertainty principle
it's not possible to observe a
velocity that's this slow for
a macroscopic object.
So, hopefully that kind of
clears up that question.
And, of course, when the
velocity actually is zero,
this equation that the de
Broglie has put forth is valid
for anything that has momentum,
so if something does
not have any velocity at all,
it actually does not have
momentum, so you can't apply
that equation anyway.
And another thing that came
up, and it came up in
remembering as I was writing
your problem set for this
week, which will be posted
sometime this afternoon, your
problem set 2, is when we're
talking about wavelengths of
particles, and for specifically
for electrons
sometimes, you're asked to
calculate what the energy is.
And I just want to remind
everyone, so this is a
separate thought here, that we
often use the energy where
energy is equal to h c divided
by wavelength.
So if we're talking about,
for example, we know the
wavelength of an electron and
we're trying to find the
energy or vice versa, is
this an equation we
can use to do that?
What do you think?
No.
Hopefully you're going
to say no.
And the reason is, and this will
come up on the problems
and a lot of students end up
using this equation, which is
why I want to head it off and
mention it ahead of time, we
can't use an equation because
this equation is very
specific for light.
We know it's very specific for
light because in this equation
is c, the speed of light.
So any time you go to use this
equation, if you're trying to
use it for an electron, just
ask yourself first, does an
electron travel at the
speed of light?
And if your answer is no, your
answer will be no, then you
just know you can't use
this equation here.
So instead you'd have to maybe
if you start with wavelength,
go over there, and then figure
out velocity and do something
more like kinetic energy
equals 1/2 n b
squared to get there.
So this is just a heads up
for as you start your
next problem set.
All right.
So jumping in to having
established that, yes,
particles have wave-like
behavior, even though no,
they're not actually photons,
we can't use that equation.
But we can use equations that
describe waves to describe
matter, and that's what we're
going to be doing today.
We're going to be looking
at the solutions to the
Schrodinger equation for
a hydrogen atom, and
specifically we'll be looking
at the binding energy of the
electron to the nucleus.
So we'll be looking at the
solution to this part of the
Schrodinger equation where
we're finding e.
Then we'll go on, after we've
made all of our predictions
for what the energy should be,
we can actually confirm
whether or not we're correct,
and we'll do this by looking
at photon emission and photon
absorption for hydrogen atoms,
and we'll actually do a demo
with that, too, so we can
confirm it ourselves, as well
as matching it with the
observation of others.
And if we have time, we'll move
on also to talking about
the other part of the solution
to the Schrodinger equation,
which is psi or this
wave function here.
And remember I said that
wave function is just a
representation of the particle,
particularly when
we're talking about electrons
-- we're familiar with the
term orbitals. psi is just a
description of the orbital.
So, we'll start with an
introduction to that if we got
to it at the end.
So, to remind you, when we
look at the Schrodinger
equation here, we have two parts
to it, so when we solve
the Schrodinger equation, we're
either finding psi,
which as I said, is a wave
function or an orbital.
And in addition to finding psi,
we can also solve to find
e or to find the energy for any
given psi, and these are
the binding energies of the
electron to the nucleus.
And the most important thing
about using the Schrodinger
equation and getting out our
solutions for potential
orbitals and potential energies
for an electron with
the nucleus, is that what
we find is that quantum
mechanics, and quantum mechanics
allowing us to get
to the Schrodinger equation,
allows us to correctly predict
and confirm our observations
for what we can actually
measure are indeed the
energy levels.
Here we're talking about a
hydrogen atom and that's what
we'll focus on today.
And it's incredibly precise
and we're able to make the
predictions and match them
with experiment.
Also, when we're looking at the
Schrodinger equation, it
allows us to explain a stable
hydrogen atom, which is
something that classical
mechanics did
not allow us to do.
So here's the solution for a
hydrogen atom, where we have
the e term here is equal to
everything written in green.
We've got a lot of constants
in this solution to the
hydrogen atom, and we know
what most of these mean.
But remember that this whole
term in green here is what is
going to be equal to that
binding energy between the
nucleus of a hydrogen atom
and the electron.
So, let's go ahead and define
our variables here, they
should be familiar to us.
We have the mass, first of all,
m is equal to m e, so
that's the electron mass.
We also have e, which
is going to be the
charge on the electron.
In addition to that, we have
that epsilon nought value,
remember that's the permittivity
constant in a
vacuum, and basically that is
what we use as a conversion
factor to get from units.
We don't want namely coulombs
to units, we want that will
allow us to cancel out
in this equation.
And finally we have Planck's
constant here, which we're all
familiar with.
So, what actually happens when
people work with the solution
to the Schrodinger equation for
a hydrogen atom is that
they don't always want to deal
with all these constants here,
so we can actually group them
together and use them as a
single new constant, and
this new constant
is the Rydberg constant.
And the Rydberg constant is
actually equal to 2 .
1 8 times 10 to the negative
18 joules.
So when we pull out all of those
constants and instead
use the Rydberg constant, what
it allows us to do is really
simplify our energy equation.
So now we have that energy is
equal to the negative of the
Rydberg constant divided
by n squared.
So, what we have left in our
equation is only one part that
we haven't explained yet, and
that is that n value.
And it turns out that when
you solve the Schrodinger
equation, you find that there
are only certain allowed
values of this integer n.
And those allowed values range
anywhere from n equals 1, you
can have n equal that 2,
3, and it goes all
the way up to infinity.
But the important part is that
there are only certain allowed
values, so for example,
you can't have 1 .
5 or 2 .
3, there are only these
interger numbers.
And this n here is
what we call the
principle quantum number.
And what we find is when we
apply n and plug it in to our
energy equation, is that what
we see is now we don't just
have one distinct answer, we
don't just have one possible
binding energy of the electron
to the nucleus.
We're going to find that we
actually have a whole bunch of
possible, in fact, an infinite
number of possible energy
levels, and that's easier
to see on this
energy diagram here.
So, let's start with n equals
1, since that's, of course,
the simplest case.
So, if we have n equals 1, we
can plug it into our energy
equation here, and find that the
binding energy, the e sub
n, for n equals 1, it's just
going to be equal to the
negative of the Rydberg
constant, so we can actually
graph that on an energy diagram
here, and it's going
to be down low at the bottom
because that's going to be, in
fact, the lowest or most
negative energy
when n equals 1.
But we saw from our equation
that there's more than just
one possible value for n, so we
could, for example, have n
equals 2, n equals 3, all the
way up to n equaling infinity.
So what this tells us here is
that this is not necessarily
the binding energy of the
electron in a hydrogen atom,
it's also possible that it
could, for example, have this
energy, it could have this
energy up here, it could have
some energy way up here.
So we have this infinite
number of
possible binding energies.
But the really important
point here is
that they're quantized.
So it's not a continuum of
energy that we can have, it's
only these punctuated points of
energy that are possible.
So as I tried to say on the
board, we can have n equals 1,
but since we can't have n equals
1/2, we actually can't
have a binding energy that's
anywhere in between these
levels that are indicated
here.
And that's a really important
point for something that comes
out of solving the Schrodinger
equation is this quantization
of energy levels.
And thanks to our equation
simplified here, it's very
easy for us to figure out what
actually the allowed energy
levels are.
So for n equals 2, what would
the binding energy be?
Someone shout it out.
Yup.
So, I think the compilation of
the voices that I heard was
negative r h over 2 squared.
We can do the same thing for 3,
negative r h over 3 squared
is going to be our
binding energy.
For 4, we can go all the way up
to infinity, and actually
when we get to the point where
it's infinity, what we find is
the binding energy at that point
is going to be zero.
And when we get to infinity,
what that means is that we now
have a free electron, so now
the electron has totally
separated from the atom.
And that makes sense because
we're at the point where
there's no binding energy
keeping it stable.
You'll also know that all of
these binding energies here
are negative, so the negative
sign indicates that it's low.
It's a more negative energy,
it's a lower energy state.
So whenever we're thinking
about energy states, it's
always more stable to be more
low in an energy well, so
that's why it makes sense that
it's favorable, in fact, to
have an electron interacting
with the nucleus that
stabilizes and lowers
the energy of that
electron by doing so.
So, we actually term this n
equals 1 state gets a special
name, which we call the ground
state, and it's called the
ground state because it is, in
fact, the lowest to the ground
that we can get.
It's the most negative and most
stable energy level that
we have. And when we think about
kind of in a more out
practical sense what we mean
by all of these binding
energies, another way that we
can put it is to give it some
physical significance, and the
physical significance of
binding energies is that they're
equal to the negative
of the ionization energies.
So, for example, in a hydrogen
atom, if you take the binding
energy, the negative of that is
going to be how much energy
you have to put in to ionize
the hydrogen atom.
So, if, for example, we were
looking at a hydrogen atom in
the case where we have the
n equals 1 state, so the
electron is in that ground
state, the ionization energy,
it makes sense, is going to be
the difference between the
ground state and the energy it
takes to be a free electron.
When we graph that on our chart
here, it becomes clear
that yes, in fact, the
ionization energy is just the
negative of the binding energy,
so we can just look
over here and figure out what
our ionization energy is.
So when we're talking about the
ground state of a hydrogen
atom, our ionization energy is
just the negative of the
Rydberg constant, so
that easy, it's 2 .
1 8 times 10 to the negative
18 joules.
So, that should make a lot of
sense intuitively, because it
makes sense that if we need to
ionize an atom, we need to put
energy into the atom in order
to eject that electron, and
that energy we need to put in
better be the difference
between where we are now and
where we have to be to be a
free electron.
So in most cases when we talk
about ionization energy, if we
don't say anything specific to
the state we're talking about,
you should always assume that we
are, in fact, talking about
the ground state.
So, oftentimes you'll just be
asked about ionization energy.
If it doesn't say anything else
we do mean n equals 1.
But, in fact, we can also talk
about the ionization energy of
different states of the hydrogen
atom or of any atom.
So, for example, we could talk
about the n equals 2 state, so
that's this state here, and it's
also what we could call
the first excited state.
So we have the ground state, and
if we excite an electron
into the next closest state,
we're at the first excited
state, or the n equals
2 state.
So, we can now calculate the
ionization energy here. it's
an easy calculation -- we're
just taking the negative of
the binding energy, again that
makes sense, because it's this
difference in energy here.
So what we get is that the
binding energy, when it's
negative, the ionization
energy is 5 .
4 5 times 10 to the negative
19 joules.
So we should be able to think
about these binding energies
and figure out the ionization
energy for any state that were
asked about.
So if we can switch over to a
clicker question here and
we'll let you do that.
And what we're asking you to
do is now tell us what the
ionization energy is of a
hydrogen atom that is in its
third excited state.
All right.
Let's take 10 more
seconds on that.
OK.
Interesting.
Usually the majority is correct,
but actually what you
did was illustrate a point that
I really wanted to stress
and there's no better way to
stress it then to get it
incorrect, especially when
it doesn't count, it
doesn't hurt so bad.
So, if you want to switch back
over to the notes, we'll
explain why, in fact, the
correct answer is 4.
So the key word here is that we
asked you to identify the
third excited state.
So, what white is n equal to for
the third excited state?
4 OK.
So that explains probably most
of the confusion here and you
just want to be careful when
you're reading the problems
that that's what you
read correctly.
I think everyone would now get
the clicker question correct.
So, the third excited state,
is n equal to 4, because n
equals 2 is first excited, 3 is
second excited, 4 is third
excited state.
So now we can just take the
negative of that binding
energy here, and I've just
rounded up here or 1 .
4 times 10 to the negative
19 joules.
So, I noticed that a few, a
very, very small proportion of
you, did type in selections
that were
negative ionization energies.
And I'll just say it right now
you can absolutely never have
a negative ionization energy,
so that's good
to remember as well.
And intuitively, it should make
sense, right, because
ionization energy is the amount
of energy you need to
put in to eject an electron
from an atom.
So you don't want to put in a
negative energy, that's not
going to help you out, you need
to put in positive energy
to get an electron out
of the system.
So that's why you'll find
binding energies are always
negative, and ionization
energies are always going to
be positive, or you could look
at the equation and see it
from there as well.
All right.
So, using the equation we'd
initially discussed, the
negative r sub h over n squared,
we could figure out
all of the different ionization
energies and
binding energies for a hydrogen
atom, and it turns
out if we change the equation
only slightly to add a
negative z squared in there, so,
negative z squared times
the Rydberg constant over
n squared, now let's us
calculate energy levels for
absolutely any atom as long as
this one important stipulation,
it only has 1
electron in it.
So basically we're dealing with
hydrogen atoms and then
we're going to be dealing
with ions.
So, for example, a helium
plus 1 ion has 1
electron at z equal 2.
A lithium 2 plus ion has 1
electron, it has z equals 3,
so if we were to plug in, we
would just do z squared up
here, or 3 squared.
Terbium 64 plus, another
1 electron atom.
What is z for that?
Yup.
65.
So again, terbium 64 plus, not
an ion we probably will run
into, but if we did, we could,
in fact, calculate all of the
energy levels for it using
this equation here.
And the difference between the
equation, the reason that that
z squared comes in there is
because if you go back to your
notes from Wednesday, and you
look at the long written out
form of the Schrodinger equation
for a hydrogen atom,
or any 1 electron atom, you see
the last term there is a
coulomb potential energy
between the
electron and the nucleus.
So, of course, when we have a
charge on the nucleus equal to
1, as we do in a hydrogen atom,
the z is equal to 1, so
it drops out there, but normally
we would have to
include the full charge on the
nucleus, which is equal to z
or the atomic number
times the electron.
So even if we strip an atom of
all of its electrons, we still
have that same amount
of positive
charge in the nucleus.
So, this allows us to look at a
bunch of different atoms, of
course, limited to the fact
that it has to be
a 1 electron atom.
So, now that we can calculate
the binding energies, we can
think about is this, in fact,
what matches up with what's
been observed, or, in fact,
could we predict what we will
observe in different kinds of
situations now that we know
how to use the binding
energy, and hopefully
we can and we will.
So one thing we could do is we
could look at the different
wavelengths of light that are
emitted by hydrogen atoms that
are excited to a higher state.
So what we'll do in a
few minutes here is
try this with hydrogen.
So we'll take h 2 and we'll run
-- or actually we'll have
h 2 filled in an evacuated
glass tube.
When we increase the potential
between the 2 electrodes that
we have in the tube -- we
actually split the h 2 into
the individual hydrogen atoms,
and not only do that, but also
excite the atoms.
So when you just run across an
atom in the street, you can
assume it's going to be in its
most stable ground state,
that's where the electron would
be, but when we add
energy to the system, we can
actually excite it up into all
different sorts of higher states
-- n equals 6, n equals
10, any of those
higher states.
But that only happens
momentarily, because, of
course, if you have an energy in
a higher energy level, it's
going to want to drop back down
to that lower or more
stable level.
And when it does that it's going
to give off some energy
equal to the difference between
those two levels.
And that will be associated
with a wavelength if it
releases the energy in
terms of a photon.
So that's what we'll look
at in a few minutes.
There's some important things
to point out about what is
happening here.
Just to visualize exactly what
we're saying, what we're
saying is when we have an energy
in a higher energy
level, so let's say energy
level, this initial level high
up here, and it drops down to
a lower final level, what we
find is that the photon that
is going to be emitted is
going to be emitted with the
exact energy, and the
important term here
is the exact.
That is the difference between
these two energy states.
That makes sense because we're
losing energy, we're going to
a level lower level, so we can
give off that extra in the
form of light.
And we can actually write the
equation for what we would
expect the energy for
the light to be.
So this delta energy here is
very simply the energy of the
initial state minus the energy
of the final state.
This is a little bit generic,
we're not actually specifying
the states here, but we could,
we know we can calculate the
energy from any of the states.
So, for example, let's say we
excited the hydrogen atom such
that the electron was starting
in the n equals 6 state, so
that's our n initial.
And we drop down to the n equals
2 state, or the first
excited state.
Then we would be able to change
our equation to make it
a little bit more specific and
say that delta energy here is
equal to energy of n equals 6,
minus the energy of the n
equals 2 state.
When we talk about that
frequency of light that's
going to be emitted, it's not
too commonly that we'll
actually talk about it
in terms of energy.
A lot of times we talk about
light in terms of its
frequency or it's wavelength,
but that's OK, because we know
how to convert from energy to
frequency, so we can do that
here as well, where our
frequency is just our energy
divided by Planck's constant,
and since here we're talking
about a delta energy, we're
going to talk about the
frequency as being equal
to delta energy over h.
Or we can say the frequency is
going to be equal to the
energy initial minus the
energy final all
over Planck's constant.
So this means that we can go
directly from the energy
between two levels to the
frequency of the photon that's
emitted when you go between
those levels.
What we can also do is say
something about the wavelength
as well because we know the
relationship between energy
and frequency and wavelength.
So, in the first case here,
let's say we go from a high
level to a low level, let's say
we go from five to one.
If we have a large energy
difference here, are we going
to have a high or
low frequency?
Good.
A high frequency.
If we have a high frequency,
what about the wavelength,
long or short?
All right.
Good.
So we should always be
able to keep these
relationships in mind.
So, similarly in a case where
instead we have a small energy
difference, we're going to have
a low frequency, which
means that we're going to have
a long wavelength here.
So now we can go ahead
and try observing
some of this ourselves.
So what we're actually going to
do is this experiment that
I explained here where we're
going to excite hydrogen atoms
such that they're electrons go
into these higher energy
levels, and then we're going to
see if we can actually see
individual wavelengths that
come out of that that
correspond with the
energy difference.
So, our detection devices are
a little bit limited here
today, we're actually only going
to be using our eyes, so
that means that we need to stick
with the visible range
of the electromagnetic
spectrum.
Actually that simplifies things,
because that really
cuts down on the number of
wavelengths that we're going
to be trying to observe here.
So it turns out that in the
visible range, when you figure
out the differences between
energy levels, in hydrogen
atoms, there's only 4
wavelengths that fall in the
visible range of the spectrum.
So hopefully, when we turn out
the lights, we're going to
turn on this lamp here, which
has hydrogen in it and we're
going to excite that hydrogen.
You'll see light coming out, but
it's, of course, going to
be bulk light -- you're not
going to be able to tell the
individual wavelengths.
So what our TAs, actually if
they can come down now, are
going to pass out to you is
these either defraction
goggles, or just a little plate,
and you're going to be
splitting that light into its
individual wavelengths.
And the glasses, there aren't
enough to go around for all of
you, so that's why
there's plates.
And though glasses do look way
cooler, the plates work a
little better, so either you or
your neighbor should try to
have one of the plates
in case one of you
can't see all the lines.
So our TAs will pass these
around for us.
And I also want to point out,
it's guaranteed pretty much
you'll be able to see these
three here in the visible
range -- you may or may not be
able to see, sometimes it's
hard to see that one that's
getting near the UV end of our
visible spectrum.
So we won't worry if
we can't see that.
I'll take one actually.
Can you raise your hand if you
if you still need one?
All right, so TA's walk
carefully now, I'm going to
shut the lights down here.
All right, so we do still have
some little bits of ambient
light, so you might
see a slight
amount of the full continuum.
But if you look through your
plate, and actually especially
if you kind of look off to the
side, hopefully you'll be able
to see the individual lines
of the spectrum.
Is everyone seeing that?
Yeah, pretty much.
OK.
Can anyone not see it?
Does anyone need -- actually
I can't even tell if
you raise your hand.
So ask your neighbor if you
can't see it and get one of
the plates if you're
having trouble
seeing with the glasses.
So this should match up with
the spectrum that we saw.
And actually keep those
glasses with you.
We'll turn the light back
on for a second here.
And hydrogen atom is what
we're learning about, so
that's the most relevant here.
But just to show you that each
atom does have its own set of
spectral lines, just for fun
we'll look at neon also so you
can have a comparison point.
All right.
So, this is probably a familiar
color having seen
many neon lights around
everywhere.
So you see with the neon is
there's just a lot more lines
in that orange part of the
spectrum then compared to the
hydrogen, and that's really what
gives you that neon color
in the neon signs.
That's the true color of a neon
being excited, sometimes
neon signs are painted
with other compounds.
All right, does everyone
have their fill of
seeing the neon lines?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: All right, let's take
two more seconds to look
at neon then.
All right.
So our special effects portion
of the class is over.
And what you see when we see it
with our eye, which is all
the wavelengths, of course,
mixed together, is whichever
those wavelengths
is most intense.
So, when we looked at the
individual neon lines, it was
the orange colors that was most
intense, which is why we
were seeing kind of a general
orange glow with the neon,
which is different from what
we see with the hydrogen.
All right, so we can, in fact,
observe individual lines.
There's nothing more exciting
to see with your glasses on,
while you look nice.
You can take those off if you
wish to, or you can try to
just be splitting the light in
the room until the TAs grab
your glasses, either is fine.
It turns out that we are far
from the first people,
although it felt exciting, we
did not discover this for the
first time here today.
In fact, J.J. Balmer, who was a
school teacher in the 1800s,
was the first to describe these
lines that could be seen
from hydrogen.
And he saw the same lines that
we saw here today, and
although he could not explain,
even start to explain why you
saw only these specific
lines and not a whole
continuum of the light.
Right, we already have an idea
because we just talked about
energy levels, we know there's
only certain allowed energy
levels, but at the time there's
no reason J.J. Balmer
should have known this, and in
fact he didn't, but he still
came up with a quantitative
way to describe
what was going on.
He came up with this equation
here where what he found was
that he could explain the
wavelengths of these different
lines by multiplying 1 over 4
minus 1 over some integer n,
and multiplying it by
this number, 3 .
29 times 10 to the 15 Hertz,
and he found that this was
true where n was some
integer value --
3, 4, 5, or 6.
So he could explain it
quantitatively in terms of
putting an equation with it, but
he couldn't explain what
was actually going on.
But we, having learned about
energy levels, having had the
Schrodinger equation solved for
us to understand what's
going on, can, in fact, explain
what happened when we
saw these different colors.
So, what we know is happening
is that were having
transitions from some excited
states to a more relaxed
lower, more stable state
in the hydrogen atom.
And it turns out what we can
detect visibly with our eyes
is in the visible range, and
that means that the final
state is n equals 2.
Because you see how n equals 1
is so much further away, and
actually that's not to scale,
it's actually much, much
further down in the energy well,
such that the energy of
the light is so great that
it's going to be in
ultraviolet very high energy,
high frequency range.
So we can't actually see any of
that, it's too high energy
for us to see.
So everything we see is going to
be where we have the final
energy state being n equals 2.
So if we think about, for
example, this red line here,
which energy state or which
principle quantum number do
you think that our electron
started in?
STUDENT: Three.
PROFESSOR: Good.
So, it's going to be in 3,
because that's the shortest
energy difference we can have,
and the red is the longest
wavelength we can see -- those 2
are inversely related, so it
must be n equals 3.
What about the kind of cyan-ish,
blue-green one?
Yup. so n equals
4 for that one.
Similarly we can go on,
match up the others.
So n equals 5 for the
bluish-purple and the violet
is n equals 6.
And again, that matches up,
because the violet, or getting
really close to the UV range
here has the longest energy,
so the highest frequency, and
that's going to be the
shortest wavelength and we can
see here it is, in fact, the
shortest wavelength that
we can actually see.
So, we can see if we can come up
with the same equation that
J.J. Balmer came up with by
actually starting with what we
know and working our way that
way instead of coming up from
the other direction, which he
did, which was just to explain
what he saw.
So, if we start instead with
talking about the energy
levels, we can relate these to
frequency, because we already
said that frequency is related
to, or it's equal to the
initial energy level here minus
the final energy level
there over Planck's constant
to get us to frequency.
And we also have the equation
that comes out of Schrodinger
equation that tell us exactly
what that binding energy is,
that binding energy is just
equal to the negative of the
Rydberg constant
over n squared.
So that means that our frequency
is going to equal,
if we plug in e n into the
initial and final energy here,
1 over Planck's constant times
negative r h over n initial
squared, minus negative r
h over n final squared.
So we have an equation that
should relate how we can
actually calculate
the frequency to
what J.J. Balmer observed.
We can simplify this equation
by pulling up the r h and
getting rid of some of these
negatives here by saying the
frequency is going to be equal
to the Rydberg constant
divided by Planck's constant
all times 1 over n final
squared -- this is just to
switch the signs around and
get rid of some negatives
-- minus 1
over n initial squared.
We can plug this in further when
we're talking about the
visible part of the light
spectrum, because we know that
for n final equals 2, then that
would mean we plug in 2
squared here, so what
we get is 1 over 4.
So this is our final equation,
and this is actually called
the Balmer series, which was
named after Balmer, and this
tells us the frequency of any
of the lights where we start
with an electron in some higher
energy level and we
drop down to an n final
that's equal to 2.
So it's a more specific version
of the equation where
we have the n final
equal to 2.
And it turns out that actually
we find that this matches up
perfectly with Balmer's
equation, because the value of
r h, the Rydberg constant
divided by the Planck's
constant is actually -- it's
also another constant, so we
can write it as this
kind of strange
looking cursive r here.
Unfortunately, this is also call
the Rydberg constant, so
it's a little bit confusing.
But really it means the Rydberg
constant divided by h,
and that's equal to 3 .
29 times 10 to the
15 per second.
So if you remember what the
equation Balmer found was this
number multiplied
by this here.
So, we found the exact same
equation, but just now
starting from understanding
the difference
between energy levels.
So, sometimes you'll find the
Rydberg constant in different
forms, but just make sure you
pay attention to units because
then you won't mess them up,
because this is in inverse
seconds here, the other Rydberg
constant is in joules,
so you'll be able to use what
you need depending on how
you're using that constant.
So in talking about the hydrogen
atom, they actually
have different names for
different series, which means
in terms of different n
values that we end in.
So we talked about what we could
see with visible light,
we said that's actually
the Balmer series.
So anything that goes from a
higher energy level to 2 is
going to be falling within the
Balmer series, which is in the
visible range of the spectrum.
We can think about the Lyman
series, which is
where n equals 1.
We know that that's going to be
a higher energy difference,
so that means that we're going
to be in the UV range.
We can also go in the
opposite direction.
So, for example, when n equals
3, that's called the Paschen
series, and these are named
after basically the people
that first discovered these
different lines and
characterized them, and this
is in the near IR range.
And again, the n equals 4 is
the Brackett series, and
that's an IR range.
I think there's names for even
a few more levels up.
You don't need to know those,
but just because it's a
special case with the hydrogen
atom, they do tend to be named
-- the most important, of
course, tends to be the Balmer
series because that's what we
can actually see being emitted
from the hydrogen atom.
So, now we should be able to
relate what we know about
different frequencies and
different wavelengths, so
Darcy can you switch us over
to a clicker question here?
And we can also talk about the
difference between what's
happening when we have emission,
and we're going to
switch over to absorption.
So, we just talked about
emission, so before we head
into absorption, if you can
answer this clicker question
in terms of what do you think
absorption means having just
discussed hydrogen
emission here?
So we have four choices in terms
of initial and final
energy levels, and also what
it means in terms of the
electron -- whether it's gaining
energy or whether it's
going to be emitting energy?
So, why do you take 10 seconds
on that, we'll
make it a quick one.
All right, great.
So already just from knowing
the emission part, we can
figure out what absorption
probably means.
Absorption is just the opposite
of emission, so
instead of starting at a high
energy level and dropping
down, when we absorb light we
start low and we absorb energy
to bring ourselves up to an
n final that's higher.
And instead of having the
electron giving off energy as
a photon, instead now the
electron is going to take in
energy from light and move
up to that higher level.
So now we're going to be talking
briefly about photon
absorption here.
So again, this is just stating
the same thing, and it could
take in a long wavelength light,
which would give it
just a little bit of energy,
maybe just enough to head up
one energy level or two, or we
could take in a high energy
photon, and that means that the
electron is going to get
to move up to an even
higher energy level.
And again, we can talk about the
same relationship here, so
it's a very similar equation to
the Rydberg equation that
we saw earlier, except now what
you see is the n initial
and the n final are
swapped places.
So instead now we have r h over
Planck's constant times 1
over n initial squared minus
n final squared.
And what you want to keep in
mind is that whatever you're
dealing with, whether it's
absorption or emission, the
frequency of the light is always
going to be a positive
number, so you always want to
make sure what's inside these
brackets here turns out
to be positive.
So that's just a little bit of
a check for yourself, and it
should make sense because what
you're doing is you're
calculating the difference
between energy levels, so you
just need to flip around which
you put first to end up with a
positive number here, and that's
a little bit of a check
that you can do what yourself.
So let's do a sample calculation
now using this
Rydberg formula, and we'll
switch back to emission, and
the reason that we'll do that is
because it would be nice to
actually approve what we just
saw here and calculate the
frequency of one of our lines
in the wavelength of one of
the lines we saw.
So what we'll do is this problem
here, which is let's
calculate out what the
wavelength of radiation would
be emitted from a hydrogen
atom if we start at the n
equals 3 level and we go down
to the n equals 2 level.
So what we need to do here is
use the Rydberg formula, and
actually you'll be given the
Rydberg formulas in both
forms, both or absorption and
emission on the exams. if you
don't want to use that, you can
also derive it as we did
every time, it should
intuitively make
sense how we got there.
But the exams are pretty short,
so we don't want you
doing that every time, so we'll
save the 2 minutes and
give you the equations directly,
but it's still
important to know
how to use them.
So, we can get from these
energy differences to
frequency by frequency is equal
to r sub h over Planck's
constant times 1 over n
final squared minus 1
over n initial squared.
So let's actually just simplify
this to the other
version of the Rydberg
constant, since we
can use that here.
So kind of that strange cursive
r, and our n final is
2, so 1 over 2 squared minus n
initial, so 1 over 3 squared.
So, our frequency of light
is going to be equal to r
times 5 over 36.
But when we were actually
looking at our different
wavelengths, what we associate
mostly with color is the wave
length of the light and not the
frequency of the light, so
let's look at wavelength
instead.
We know that wavelength
is equal to c over nu.
We can plug in what we have
for nu, so we have 36 c
divided by 5, and that cursivey
Rydberg constant, and
that gives us 36 times the
speed of light, 2 .
998 times 10 the 8 meters per
second, all over 5 times 3 .
29 times 10 to the
15 per second.
So, what we end up getting when
we do this calculation is
the wavelength of light,
which is equal to 6 .
57 times 10 to the negative 7
meters, or if we convert that
to nanometers, we have
657 nanometers.
So does anyone remember what
range of light 657
nanometers falls in?
What color?
STUDENT: Red.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
in the red range.
So that's promising.
We did, in fact, see red in our
spectrum, and it turns out
that that's exactly the
wavelength that we see is that
we're at 657 nanometers.
So it turns out that we can, in
fact, use the energy levels
to predict, and we could if we
wanted to do them for all of
the different wavelengths of
light that we observed, and
also all the different
wavelengths of light that can
be detected, even if we
can't observe them.
All right, so that's what we're
going to cover in terms
of the energy portion of the
Schrodinger equation.
I mentioned that we can also
solve for psi here, which is
the wave function, and we're
running a little short on
time, so we'll start on
Monday with solving
for the wave function.